à l'ère industrielle toute activité
laisse des traces elles sont bien
connues ce sont les déchets en fait
toute production ou toute consommation
d'énergie entraîne la formation de
déchets lorsqu'il était organique
surtout lorsqu'il y en avait peu nature
savez les effacer mieux encore les
récupérer mais aujourd'hui on a
l'impression qu'il est rassasié des
déchets de l'homme les cendres les
fumées les ordures ménagères les
plastiques non dégradables s'accumulent
la planète déborde de nos salles tit i
portant nous avons besoin de toujours
plus d'énergie
donc il nous faudra brûler plus de
charbon plus de pétrole donc faire plus
de fumée à moins que l'énergie atomique
ne rompe le cercle infernal
car la matière nucléaire se consume
s'enflamme et sont fumés l'ère atomique
que serait-elle propre à mais peut-être
cache-t-elle des déchets plus pernicieux
encore invisible et à
[Musique]
la puissance atomique c'est bien connu à
deux visages le premier inquiète le
voici celle arme atomique
le second est pacifique il offre
l'énergie de la matière il permet l'âge
d'or de l'électricité il mène à la
construction des centrales nucléaires
mais soudain que se passe-t-il l'atome
pacifique est à son tour contesté le 10
mai 1971 à fessenheim plusieurs
centaines de personnes manifestent le 10
juillet 1971 à bugey cette fois ci où
une centrale doit être construite
un comité de défense réuni plus de dix
mille manifestants en colère
ils protestent contre la menace que la
centrale se re fait peser sur la santé
des populations et notamment sur leur
capital génétique c'est-à-dire sur leur
hérédité aux états unis où le mouvement
d'opposition a pris une ampleur
nationale
les comités de défense ce multi paix la
fin de l'année 1970 il obtenait
l'annulation de la construction de dix
centrales et provoquer de graves retards
pour la mise en route de 50 autres le
développement du programme nucléaire
américain est en cause à l'heure où la
construction des centrales nucléaires se
généralise tout le monde ne ressens pas
cette nouvelle peur atomique
c'est apparemment le cas des habitants
de saint-laurent-des-eaux petit village
des bords de la loire où sont implantés
les deux principales centrales
nucléaires françaises
vous êtes le maire d'une commune sur
laquelle il y à une centrale nucléaire
depuis quelques années parce que c'était
difficile cette implantation
cette implantation a posé des problèmes
c'est certain que vous administrez à mes
administrés et depuis que la centrale
fonctionne ce qu'il y a des inquiétudes
nouvelle un nom du brut la centrale
fonctionne il n'y a plus d'inquiétudes
sur le village on en trouve
paradoxalement dans les environs à une
certaine distance
parce que dans un souci de sécurité
l'edf fait faire des prélèvements il
fait des relevé à quelques kilomètres
aux alentours car c'est la sécurité qui
inquiète plus près la sécurité oui si
les habitants de saint laurent des eaux
sont rassurés il en va peut être
autrement dans d'autres municipalités
c'est pourquoi le df reçoit aujourd'hui
une centaine de représentants de ces
municipalités
[Musique]
au programme de la journée
il ya certes la visite des installations
de saint-laurent-des-eaux mais aussi un
déjeuner débat au cours duquel les joies
de la convivialité aussi la discussion
avec les représentants de l'edf devrait
effacer les malentendus éventuelles est
ce que nous pourrions aujourd'hui
équipés d'un vêtement quel ennui nous
pouvons avoir vous avez pu voir ce matin
à saint laurent les précautions qui sont
prises
ce qui inquiète surtout les convives
c'est que le mal atomique les radiations
sont pour eux un mal inconnu
nous devrions dire un mal mystérieux et
c'est cela sans doute qui explique le
malaise mais pour un spécialiste comme
le docteur jamais les effets des
radiations sont maintenant bien connu il
nous les expliquer les radiations se
comporte par exemple vis-à-vis de la
peau comme se comportent tout agent
agresseurs extérieurs c'est pas les
radiations qui font que la preuve d'une
certaine façon c'est que la peau ne sait
réagir que d'une seule façon si vous
allez au soleil sur une plage la peau
rougit et ensuite elles paient les
squames si vous soumettez les la même
peau à l'action des radiations
ionisantes est bien l rougira et puis si
la dose est suffisamment élevée elle de
ce coma et il n'y a pas de différence de
nature
ce n'est pas un mal mystérieux non mais
alors on manière d'irradiation je crois
qu'il ya un problème celui de la
sommation c'est à dire que notre
organisme
chaque fois qu'il reçoit dose
d'irradiation il la conserve en quelque
sorte et toutes les doses qu'il vaudra
ce qu'il va recevoir ensuite vont
s'ajouter et que finalement même en
prenant que deux petites doses chaque
fois au bout de toute une vie ça fait
peut-être une grosse dose alors est ce
qu'il n'ya pas un danger à long terme
et même si on dépasse le temps d'une
génération est ce que à travers
l'hérédité il n'y a pas un danger pour
les générations futures
même si les doses actuellement son
faible pour les radiations ionisantes il
n'ya pas toujours sommation dans
l'immense majorité des cas il y as au
compteur restauration c'est à dire
qu'une cellule qui a été radié restaure
les dégâts qui ont pu être commis elle
est réparée elle même très bien et les
organismes un organisme vivant irradiait
récupère
c'est ça le cas général et l'exception
c'est la non récupération il faut pas
transformer l'exception en règle
les seuls
les seules choses que nous risquons
dormir l'atmosphère ce sont des
effluents les gens de dampierre c'est la
seule question qui les préoccupent
surtout sur le foncier ça provoque quand
même une certaine influence qu'avant ces
terrains-là trouvait facilement preneur
étant donné que la région était une
région tout à fait tranquille à tous
points de vue et les gens n'est ce pas y
venaient s'y détendre
il ne cherchait le calme et ça les a un
petit peu dérangé voyez-vous et ils
abandonnent leur projet oui
effectivement l'opinion semble
actuellement forte inquiète les
inconvénients que peut représenter nos
centrales nucléaires
on peut s'expliquer difficilement cette
réaction actuellement puisque
actuellement nous sommes assez nous
sommes très maître du problème comme les
conseillers municipaux nous avons nous
aussi interrogé les représentants de
l'edf
ils ne sont plus au restaurant mais dans
la centrale elle-même dans la salle de
contrôle
une pile atomique c'est un petit peu une
bombe atomique ralentit alors est ce
qu'il n'ya pas un risque d'explosion
par exemple
c'est absolument impossible impossible
ceci lui pour la raison le suivant que
j'essaie de vous traduire brièvement
c'est que dans un réacteur nucléaire en
emploi du combustible à l'uranium dont
la teneur en matières fissiles et très
faible de l'or elle est de l'ordre de 0
7% pour l'uranium naturel de 3 4% pour
l'uranium légèrement enrichi qui est
utilisé dans les réacteurs à eau légère
par exemple alors que pour une bombe ont
fait appel à de l'uranium à peu près 100
% anti blanc pur ici même à saint
laurent des eaux je crois qu'il y à
quelques temps il y a eu un accident
certains barreaux de combustible ont
fondu il ya eu des contaminations dire
qu'il est contamination non le monde est
pas exact il y a eu contamination à
l'intérieur du circuit primaire qui est
une enceinte
justement chargé de le préserver
l'extérieur vis-à-vis de cette
possibilité de contamination des
températures extrêmement élevées et les
fortes pressions qui règne au coeur du
réacteur ainsi que l'incroyable
enchevêtrement de la tuyauterie nous
laisse facilement imaginer qu'un
accident est toujours possible
d'ailleurs il ya une quinzaine d'années
un rapport américain avait estimé que
l'accident maximum qui puisse résulter
de la plus grande malchance possible du
plus mauvais concours de circonstances
pourraient tuer 3400 personnes en
blesser quarante mille autres et exigé
l'évacuation de près d'un demi million
d'individus
le rapport ajoute t il est vrai que
cette éventualité catastrophique était
aussi peu probable que l'écrasement d'un
avion de ligne
un dimanche après-midi dans un stade
occupé par 80000 spectateurs et dans les
fêtes il faut reconnaître que dans la
vie des centrales nucléaires
aucun incident n'a encore fait de
victime
mais la fission de l'uranium dans le
coeur du réacteur abouti à la formation
de plus de 200 produits de fission tous
fortement radioactifs alors sans même
qu'il y ait d'accident ou d'incident
on peut toujours craindre une fuite ou
qu'un défaut d'étanchéité n'amène à
centrale a relevé son environnement
en effet on le sait les produits
radioactifs sont indestructibles
chacun a une durée de vie qui lui est
propre pendant laquelle sa radioactivité
reste constante quoi que l'on puisse
faire
elle tombe ensuite de moitié pour une
durée tout aussi longue et ainsi de
suite
cette unité de temps qui régit la vie
d'un corps radioactif est appelée la
période pour certains corps elle n'est
que de quelques secondes et le danger
disparaît donc très vite
pour d'autres elle s'étend sur plusieurs
dizaines d'années et constitue alors un
véritable problème
un véritable danger à la centrale de
saint laurent vous êtes aujourd'hui on
peut dire que pratiquement il ne sort
pas de produits de fission n'y a que des
produits d'activation du gaz carbonique
qui sert à refroidir les éléments
nuisibles
ces produits d'activation sont
essentiellement l'argon à l'argon qui a
une période de 1h30
donc vous voyez une période courte et
que si il peut produire un léger
augmentation de la radioactivité à
l'extérieur ne peut absolument pas
s'accumuler vous avez parlé des
centrales du type de
saint-laurent-des-eaux mais dans
l'avenir
les centrales seront surtout du type à
eau légère
or à ce moment là que sont les gaz qui
s'échappent à ce moment là dans les
centrales à eau légère
effectivement il ya des gaz de fission
qui sont essentiellement des gaz rares
c'est à dire des gaz chimiquement inerte
qui ne risque pas de pénétrer de se
fixer dans l'organisme et qui donc ne
présente qu'un risque d'irradiation
externe parle souvent du tritium
on parle du tritium effectivement le
tritium présente une particularité c'est
que d'abord sa période est longue donc à
la différence de beaucoup d'autres
produits radioactifs
il peut poser à long terme un problème
d'accumulation votre particularité c'est
un isotope de l'hydrogène donc
chimiquement analogue à l'hydrogène et
le tritium qui va se former va se
combiner avec l'eau et il ne sera pas
possible par des procédés chimiques
classique d'épurer le tritium présents
dans l'eau donc à ce titre le tritium
présente une particularité gênant oui
mais alors ce triste yom ce produit
finalement un piége abl on s'en
débarrasse actuellement d'une façon
disons très sain pour le jette dans la
rivière
oui mais il faut être bien conscient que
la nuisance du tri siam est très faible
et tout de même on a estimé je crois que
en l'an 2000 avec
selon les programmes prévus il y aurait
du fait du tritium plus de 96 millions
de curies dans l'air est ce que ce n'est
pas beaucoup d'eux mêmes oui les
américains ont fait des études
effectivement en se basant sur des
hypothèses optimistes de production de
développement de la production nucléaire
et on arrive à des quantités de curry
importante mais attention le curry ne
signifie rien ce qu'il faut voir c'est
l'effet sur le corps humain et cet effet
se traduit vous le savez en me lire m eh
bien ces mêmes études ont montré qu'en
l'an 2000 les doses du temps au tritium
qu'à d'autres coulent corps à vie longue
et est inférieur aux mille irait le
mieux romy lire l intérieur ohmi l'irem
je situerais ça par exemple par rapport
à la dose que je reçois mois du fait de
que je porte une montre avec un cadran
lumineuse c'est à dire un cadran sur
lequel il ya une peinture au radium et
qui entraîne pour moi chacun chaque
année de l'ordre de 5000 irène quand
cinq fois plus que les radiations que
l'on peut attendre l'an 2000 en demies
de la généralisation du programme
nucléaire exactement
mais la centrale laisse échapper un
autre polluant immatériel celui là c'est
la chaleur pour une calorie transformée
en électricité 2 reste sous forme de
chaleur et sont rejetés à la rivière
dont la température s'élève cela est
très gênant pour les autres usines tout
d'abord et aussi lorsque par exemple
cela provoque la prolifération du
plancton qui alors consomme l'oxygène de
l'eau du fleuve
elle peut aussi perturber les moeurs des
poissons notamment en période de fraie
ce problème n'est pas spécifique des
centrales nucléaires il est commun à
toutes les centrales qu'elles soient
classiques ou nucléaires et nous
protestons nous d'ailleurs et l'excès de
france contre ce vocabulaire pollution
thermique car en fait dans bien des cas
l'élévation de température de la rivière
pu être un élément favorable ça peut
être un élément pour dégeler des canaux
pour faciliter la navigation en période
de grand froid et par conséquent a
déclaré c'est une pollution me paraît un
jugement assez rapide
il est exact qu'on était quand la
température de l'eau est élevé on peut
craindre là que ça prenne le caractère
d'une chaîne ce problème ne nous a pas
échappé nous l'étudions depuis 1961 à la
centrale de montreuil nous avons créé un
laboratoire d'hydrobiologie qui permet
de fabriquer artificiellement des
climats aquatique avec beaucoup de
précision au dixième de degré centigrade
près cette élévation de température est
elle très importante elle peut atteindre
dans les conditions les plus
défavorables et dans l'état actuel de
nos installations 7 degrés
le remède existe c'est la tour de
refroidissement metz et tours coûtent
chers et peuvent quelquefois dénaturer
le paysage surtout si l'on retient
certains projets de près de 170 mètres
de haut on peut donc craindre que
bientôt les rivières ne soit saturé et
que les centrales nucléaires ne puisse
trouver asile au bord de l'océan
il faut aussi voir plus loin et penser
que les centrales vieillissent on
prévoit pour elle une durée de vie d'au
moins vingt années après lesquels il
faudra les stopper mais même au repos
certaines parties resteront actives ou
plus exactement radioactifs pendant des
années pendant des dizaines d'années
elles resteront de grandiose monument
interdite témoin de la puissance et de
la faiblesse de l'homme devant les
forces de la matière au delà de l'an
2000 ces ruines du xxème siècle risque
d'être très nombreuses
selon vous quelle est la plus gênante
qui a pu peu le ventre la centrale
nucléaire ou la centrale classique alors
je suis personnellement convaincue que
la plus agréable du point de vue du
voisinage
c'est la centrale nucléaire je suis
conseiller municipal dans une petit pays
où j'ai une maison secondaire
j'avoue que si j'avais un choix à faire
je prendrai la centrale nucléaire
oui
en tant que citoyen moi je dis je dirais
que je suis sensibilisé sur ces
problèmes de pollution notre
environnement auquel nous assistons tous
mais je suis convaincu que l'énergie
nucléaire est la seule le seul remède
envisageable pour la production
d'énergie propre et si vous deviez
accueillir demain non pas une centrale
nucléaire une centrale classique à
charbon qu'est ce que vous préférez une
charge d'une centrale à charbon nous
paraîtrait peut-être maintenant que nous
sommes habitués à la proximité de la
centrale de glay une forme un peu
archaïque où elle entraînerait
certainement des transports de matériaux
par voie ferrée et des fumées autre
inconvénient que nous n'avons absolument
pas avec la centrale nucléaire vient
vraiment aucun problème pour les
centrales nucléaires
on peut dire que les centrales
nucléaires c'est actuellement la façon
de faire de l'électricité sans pollution
c'est vos gains d'autre part il sort de
ses centrales nucléaires quand on est
hors charges par exemple des
combustibles irradiés
ces combustibles irradiés sont traités
alors les usines qui traite les
combustibles irradiés
elle en déroger c'est vers l'une de ces
léproserie nucléaire que roule cette
étrange qu'à lyon
son chargement de l'uranium extrêmement
radioactif
il vient d'une centrale tout est prévu
le camion peu en percuter un autre tombé
de 15 mètres ou même être ravagé par les
flammes
le chargement lui résistera
[Musique]
le château c'est ainsi que l'on appelle
le conteneur à rival usine de
retraitement
nous sommes à la hague prés de cherbourg
c'est là que sont prises en charge tous
les éléments actifs engendrés par le
programme nucléaire français
ici le béton est roi la guette une usine
forteresse mais là le danger n'est pas à
l'extérieur il est à l'intérieur
derrière ces murs épais en effet la
chaîne de fabrication qui permettra
entre autres de récupérer le plutonium
est de conditionner les déchets
dangereux est extrêmement radioactive
cette usine géante est prévu pour faire
face aux besoins de l'ensemble de la
production du programme atomique
européen de la prochaine décennie
et cette cheminée que représente-t-elle
n'était pas là fuient la brèche
inévitable par laquelle se déverse un
atmosphère les dangers de l'atome
pacifique
cette cheminée ne dégage pas de fumée
parce qu'aussi bien elle rejette de
l'air et de l'air filtré dans cet air
filtré il faut être conscient qu'il ya
quelques gaz radioactif mais nous les
contrôlons en particulier llyod est
contrôlé par le lait vous n'avez jamais
remarqué tout de même quelques fois
quelques pointes de radioactivité dans
l'atmosphère de la région nous avons
observé des pointes de radioactivité
dans les précipitations de maastricht en
particulier au cours des explosions
aériennes en particulier chinoise et
nous avons pu très bien détecté cette
pointe de radioactivité mais elle
n'était pas dû au sens de la hague
rien de local l'airial pacifique
l'usiné de la hague est comme un malade
contagieux sans arrêt surveiller sans
arrêt contrôle et que la moindre fuite
soit décelée et les équipes
d'intervention installe sur les lieux
l'étrange campement que voici
le
tous
mais
[Musique]
l'alerté passée
reste à vérifier que les pompiers de
l'atome ne sont pas eux mêmes
contaminées
mais que faire des déchets des plus
simples comme ses vêtements ses gants et
tout ce petit matériel de tissus et de
plastique
jusqu'au plus nocifs comme les
concentrés liquides qui sont les résidus
de la chaîne de traitement selon leur
degré d'activité ils sont soit jetés
dans des fosses comme celles ci soient
recueillies dans des bidons
[Musique]
les déchets les plus actifs et surtout
les plus durables sont enfermés eux dans
des cercueils de béton liquide ou solide
la poubelle atomique ne devient pas
moins gigantesques alors où faudra-t-il
entreposer tout cela
[Musique]
la solution préconisée et celle des
mines de sel c'est à dire des endroits
qui gèle géologiquement parlant sont
secs et qui permettent d'absorber des
températures assez élevées puisque ces
corps radioactifs dégage de la chaleur
et que les mines de sel peuvent manquer
encaissé ce déjà dégagement calorifique
encore faut-il avoir ses mines de sel
alors les états unis d'amérique en
dispose en particulier la ville de
laâyoune au texas
les allemands ou la mini daz les
français en europe il n'a pas beaucoup à
part l'allemagne
par conséquent cette solution mine de
sel si elle était retenue elle ne
pourrait pas être je ne pourrais pas
qu'une solution nationale ce serait une
solution à l'échelle de l'europe
c'est vraiment la seule solution non il
ya d'autres solutions qui ont été
étudiées en particulier les
enfouissements dans le sol à grande
profondeur
le procédé consiste à créer
artificiellement des cavités
souterraines soit par de l'eau sous
pression soit par bombe atomique
puisque ça a été recherchée en partie en
urss il ya eu des essais mais assez
confidentielle sur ce procédé à la règle
le terrain ce prêtre est assez bien à ce
stockage pour un effet des études qui
permettrait de stocker à environ 800 m
de profondeur s'est produit très
radioactifs en faisant la clé courte
entend des explosions nucléaires dans le
sous-sol dans le sous-sol oui une
explosion atomique souterraine l'atome
guerrier au service à l'atome pacifique
exactement mais tout de même vous ne
faites pas simplement que engrangé
conserver et gardez vous rejetez des
choses aussi dans le maire eiser oui et
alors il faudrait là il n'y a pas de
danger pour le moment nous avons des
autorisations de rejets qui
correspondent à des normes
internationales qui ont été acceptée par
la plupart des par la majorité des pays
et nous tenons systématiquement très en
dessous de nos possibilités de roger à
quelques pour cent de nos possibilités
maximum de roger longue de 5 km sous la
mer
la canalisation déverse chaque heure par
trente mètres de fond de 20 à 50 mètres
cubes d'eau suspecte il fallait être
certain qu'il n'y avait pas là une
menace pour les poissons et les
crustacés et pour la santé de ceux qui
les pêchent et qui léman pour être sûr
de la dispersion rapide des eaux
contaminées
des études ont été faites d'abord sur
des maquettes puis dans la mère
elle-même avec des colorants quant aux
espèces vivantes qui peuplent les fonds
marins dans ces régions elles sont
étudiées et contrôler en permanence pour
les atomistes de lag
certaines d'entre elles sont de
véritables enregistreurs infiniment plus
sensible que les appareils de mesures
les plus subtiles
[Musique]
même les algues sont surveillés ainsi il
faut reconnaître qu'à proximité même des
rejets la côte de l'agreste accueillant
aussi bien pour les pêcheurs que pour
les nageurs
[Musique]
récemment donc il ya eu des
manifestations aux états unis en france
au point des centrales nucléaires
mais vous avez ici à l'ags peut-être
finalement beaucoup plus radioactivité
est ce qu'il n'ya pas des problèmes avec
la population je crois que les problèmes
se posent lorsque l'information est en
effet insuffisamment lorsque l'on essaye
de cacher quelque chose
depuis le démarrage de l'usiné
nous nous sommes efforcés de d'informer
les autorités locales responsables et
même la population de ce qui se passait
ici de ce que nous traitions nous
n'avons jamais caché une nuisance
radioactives
mais nous avons également fait part des
contrôles que nous faisions et
d'évolution de la radioactivité qui se
passait dans l'environnement du centre
je crois que les spécialistes s'entoure
un peu trop de mystères peut-être n'ont
pas fait assez de l'information à la
portée du public
j'ai entendu dire beaucoup de fois la
radio même à la télévision le foie un
technicien dix ans je ne peux pas
m'expliquer parce que je ne peux pas
faire de vulgarisation et je crois que
c'est une erreur
il faut parler du danger radioactif il
ne faut pas le cacher il existe et il
faut l'informer dans des termes clairs
le grand public et je pense que
actuellement nous avons parlé évoquer
les problèmes de déchets nous avons
résolu parce qu'ils sont à une échelle
relativement faible mais il faut pas se
cacher et compte tenu du développement
un peu explosif du programme
électronucléaire dans le monde que le
problème des déchets ce deviendra
extrêmement important vers 1980 et vers
l'an 2000 par conséquent il faut y
penser dès maintenant
les experts avancent des chiffres
selon eux les déchets représenteront
dans le monde en 1980 30 milliards de
curry et vingt ans après seulement en
l'an 2000 400 milliards de curry selon
eux toujours l'élément le plus gênant
sera alors le plutonium celui du moins
que l'on n'a pas pu récupérer car sa
période est de 24 mille ans en l'an 2000
il y en aura dix tonnes c'est pourquoi
aujourd'hui nucléaire de genève en 1971
le professeur alvin weinberg du
laboratoire national d'oak ridge aux usa
at il proposé l'édification de parcs de
l'énergie ses parcs ses réserves
nucléaire comprendre est tout à la fois
les centrales atomiques
l' usine de retraitement et le cimetière
des déchets ces espaces réservés serait
internationaux est construit sur les
côtes ou même sur des îles artificielles
selon alvin weinberg
si l'on ne fait pas ses parcs nucléaires
les nations sans rivages seront bientôt
condamner asphyxie
[Musique]
si fermement convaincu que s'il n'y a
pas d'accord internationaux les pays qui
disposent pas de conditions climatiques
qui ne disposent pas de fleuve à grand
débit ou de grandes étendues d'eau ou de
côte serait serait neutralisé dans leur
programme électronucléaire avec les
dents les nouvelles normes qui vont être
imposés et ce besoin est urgent ce qu'il
faut se décider vite
je crois qu'il faut se décider vite
parce que comme je voulais rappeler tout
à l'heure le programme électronucléaire
se développe d'une façon exponentielle
et que par conséquent c'est dès
maintenant qu'il faut rechercher ces
sites et il n'y a pas il n'a pas
tellement dans le monde des 75 il
faudrait que les six soit déjà
répertoriés sur la mappemonde ici trois
ans des six trois ans je crois et sinon
et bien sinon nous risquons d'avoir une
certaine anarchie
on aura localement peut-être à l'échelon
national des mouvements de défense qui
risquons de sinon d'arrêter de loin de
ralentir très gravement le programme
électronucléaire les parcs de l'énergie
ne sont pas encore une préoccupation
pour nos convives trois ans pour eux
c'est l'époque où leur centrale sera
peut-être en construction l'exemple de
saint-laurent-des-eaux les a sans doute
rassuré pour peu qu'à l'avenir on sache
rester aussi vigilant qu'aujourd'hui et
puis ils sont peut-être conscient qu'il
n'y a pas de progrès sans une certaine
gêne il faut savoir choisir et là le
choix paraît simple si l'on pense que
finalement une centrale à charbon de
1000 mégawatts projette chaque année 150
mille tonnes d'oxydé de soufre 50 mille
tonnes de gaz carbonique
elle rejette même du radium 226 un
élément radioactif dont la période est
de 1600 20 ans alors une centrale
nucléaire
pourquoi pas
[Musique]